the northernmost stretch of thailand's
border with myanmar
is a natural one the doi nangnong
mountain range
while the landscape might be beautiful
it makes it difficult for thai army
patrols to search for migrants crossing
illegally
with concern growing over myanmar's
increase in covid19 cases
those patrols have grown bigger and more
frequent
this says the number of migrants
attempting to cross has surged over the
last several weeks
thailand has been much more successful
in controlling covid19
and has better healthcare the thai
border areas are on high alert many of
the crossings take place at night
making it easier to avoid being caught
but also increasing the danger
one of those migrants who risked the
night crossing a mother of two
in thailand illegally were hiding her
face
ann used to sort avocados on the thai
side of the border but in may she
sneaked back into myanmar to see her
mother before she died
she returned to her house a few weeks
ago it's been tense with her thai
neighbors since
she says they treat her like a disease
and informed local authorities
that she returned
everybody is scared of it but it was
absolutely necessary for us to come back
i was prepared to notify the local
health volunteers and the head of the
village
it was along this stretch of the sci
river that serves as the border
that anne and her daughter snuck back
into thailand because
of monsoonal rains it was swollen and
fast moving her daughter
had to ride on the shoulders of someone
who was crossing at the same time
it's not just anne's neighborhood one
group that works with migrants is also
seeing cases of locals alerting
authorities
about people who've crossed illegally
if they come into the community after
illegally crossing and people see them
they will notify immigration they don't
care
there's only a trickle of cargo passing
through the usually bustling masai
border post
since the rapid spread in myanmar more
precautions have been put in place at
the official crossing
we coordinate with the department of
disease control to intensify the
checking of cargo vehicles
and their drivers but as the situation
worsens in myanmar people seeking safety
and better health care
will continue to take the risk and cross
over any way they can
scott hiller al jazeera masai thailand